alors l'utopie peut-elle révolutionné la
musique fortune collectif pense que oui
et la musique est elle vraiment besoin
d'une révolution alors la fortune
collectif pour ce que vous vivez
guerrero y est ce que moi je suis
musicien et je joue donc dans un groupe
comme l'a dit aurélien avec lequel on
fait pas mal de concerts avec lequel on
enregistre aussi beaucoup mais quelque
part si on veut continuer si on veut
avancer il va nous falloir faire
certaines choses c'est à dire que dans
quelques années on va devoir trouver un
label une maison de disque on va
probablement devoir trouver des attachés
de presse des tourneurs et c est ce
qu'ils vont nous dire pouvoir faire leur
travail c'est sorti un album précédé cd
mais pour être honnête sortir un album
est précédée cd ça nous intéresse
vraiment moyen
dans la mesure où on est à l'ère du
numérique c'est à dire qu'on peut
vraiment sortir la musique sur le format
que l'on veut nous on va sortir par
exemple un mini album va sortir un mini
album dans moins d'un mois
et on a décidé de sortir sur des clés
usb aurait pu sortir sur des disques
durs sur un smartphone sur une console
peu importe ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que aujourd'hui on pourrait sortir
la musique / vraiment le format de notre
choix mais on va quand même entendre
encore à la sortie sortait un album est
précédée ces mais moi personnellement
j'ai probablement acheté trois albums
dans ma vie je sais parler franchement
peut-être peut-être limite moi j'ai
peut-être été un peu chaud en disant
trois albums il est besoin que ce soit 2
ou un album parce que c'est un peu ce
que c'est un support qui ne me parle pas
j'ai pas je veux dire j'écoute
principalement la musique sur internet
et je ne me retrouve plus dans le format
album dans le fait d'avoir une
collection de douze morceaux qui vont
faire entre trois et quatre minutes
puisque aujourd'hui on peut faire tout
ce qu'on veut en fait alors pourquoi le
faire de cette façon là moi je dirais
que récemment il m'est arrivé
de voir deux utilisations vraiment
pertinente du format cd c'est celle ci
est celle là voilà mais à part ça part
ça j'ai vraiment pas de j'ai rarement vu
un avantage du cd aujourd'hui en 2016
est donc là je suis quand même un petit
peu de mauvaise foi parce qu'il ya une
alternative au cd aujourd'hui c'est pas
tout à fait vrai on n'est plus
entièrement dans l'ère du cd il existe
ce qu'on appelle le streaming avec des
plateformes comme spotify deezer saïdal
etc
mais même si le streaming est une 10 ans
une solution intéressante pour les
maisons de disques sa lettre est
moyennement pour les artistes puisque
regardé comme vous pouvez le voir sur le
graphique
un artiste gagne 100 euros quand il vend
100 albums mais ils gagnent 100 euros
quand il est écouté deux cent cinquante
mille fois en streaming payant est un
million de fois en streaming gratuit ce
qui veut dire que si vous écoutez votre
artiste préféré sur spotify sans payer
presque comme si vous ne lui donnez rien
au final
financièrement parlant donc j'ai
toujours pas à ce niveau là avec le
streaming trouvé la solution pour mon
groupe pour pouvoir continuer à faire ce
que j'aime
d'une façon que je trouve original et
surtout d'une façon qui me convient qui
en résonance avec mes envies et avec les
possibilités que j'ai et une intuition
qu'on a avec avec ce groupe c'est que
peut-être on pourrait se tourner vers la
dématérialisation de la musique
alors qu'est ce que c'est la
dématérialisation de la musique c'est
tout simplement le fait qu'on soit
aujourd'hui si lourd dans le numérique
que la musique n'a plus besoin d'objets
elle a plus besoin d'être attaché un
objet la musique c'est aujourd'hui c'est
des fichiers mp3 wave et c'est qu'on
peut stocker dans un ordinateur on n'a
plus besoin du vinyle en a plus besoin
du cd on peut on peut on peut se
détacher de l'objet est un exemple assez
frappant qui a été fait de qui est de
l'utilisation de la dématérialisation de
la musique qui a été fait en 2016 c'est
la sortie du dernier album de kanye west
donc le rappeur américain puisque ce
qu'elle fait kanye west c'est qu'il a
sorti un album que vous ne pouvez pas
trouver en magasin tout simplement vous
ne trouverez que sur internet
ce n'est pas la peine il n'y a pas de ça
il n'ya pas d'objets est quelque chose
qui est très intéressant qu'il a fait
est là j'ai le sentiment que j'ai le
sentiment que personne ne l'a fait
auparavant
c'est qu'il modifie son album encore
aujourd'hui il est déjà sorti il ya
quelques mois mais si vous êtes abonnés
à la newsletter de kanye west vous
pouvez recevoir des mails comme voilà
alors kanye west a rajouté un morceau il
a enlevé un morceau il a enlevé des
paroles à un morceau et ça c'est quand
même assez intéressant ça fait que
l'album est vivant il se peut que si je
rentre chez moi ce soir et que je décide
de l'écouter ce ne soit plus le même
album le même album que ce matin ce qui
est quand même une utilisation je trouve
assez ingénieuse du fait que la musique
se soit séparé de l'objet mais il en est
ce que la dématérialisation de la
musique signifie réellement la mort de
l'objet fortune collectif pense que non
au contraire je dirais que fortune
collective pense que la
dématérialisation peut être la naissance
de l'objet au sens où puisque la musique
l'année site ne nécessite plus un objet
particulier et bien la musique peut se
trouver dans absolument tous les objets
c'est à dire que puisque la musique se
retrouve en simple fichier on pourrait
stocker de la musique dans ma chaussure
dans ma chemise ou même dans ce
téléphone bonjour bienvenue chez fortune
collective
si vous voulez écouter une nouvelle
chanson appuyé sur un
c'est appuie jean merci
ce téléphone pourrait se trouver dans un
lieu public dans une cabine téléphonique
par exemple ça veut dire que tout le
monde y auraient accès pourrez y écouter
de la musique et pourrait acheter de la
musique en insérant une pièce quelque
part et en recevant un code de
téléchargement pour l'écouter chercher
chez lui à la maison c'est une chose qui
est tout à fait possible aujourd'hui
c'est une chose que collectives qu'avoir
une collective a déjà fait une autre
chose que fortune collective a déjà fait
ses soucis ça veut dire que dans cette
boîte
vous pourrez trouver un biscuit et dans
ce biscuit
vous trouverez un code de téléchargement
avec ça vous pouvez écouter de la
musique chez vous et une utilisation qui
peut être intéressante en fait de ce
biscuit c'est simplement de collaborer
avec une une boîte de livraisons de
nourriture à domicile mais ton et de
nous comment dire de faire en sorte que
cette boîte de livraison lorsqu'il vous
apportent de la nourriture vie de nos
biscuits avec et que donc sans que vous
ayez peut-être pu connaître les artistes
qui se trouve sur le code de
téléchargement la musique soit venu à
vous comme par magie comme pas su par
surprise sans que vous l'attendiez en
fait donc ça c'est encore une chose qui
est tout à fait possible grâce à grasse
tout simplement allez pas vous avec les
journées et pourquoi s'en priver
finalement mais bon je parle de fortune
collectif depuis tout à l'heure mais
j'ai pas dit qu'ils s'étaient alors
voilà qui est fortune collective une
émission fortune collectif c'est un
collectif international qui est basé à
bruxelles
dedans vous trouverez des musiciens vous
trouverez des artistes visuels
vous trouverez des tourneurs des
managers et finalement en fait peut-être
toute personne intéressée par la musique
et le futur de la musique
méthon c'est un collectif dans lequel il
faut bien l'avouer la plupart des
membres ont un pied dans le système que
je décrivais jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant
c'est à dire que je semblais a critiqué
un système mais je dois bien avouer que
le cd je n'ai pas envie de sortir je
vais probablement le sortir l'année
prochaine je les dis il ya des tourneurs
il ya des managers dans ce collectif ce
sont des gens qui font fonctionner le
système dont je parlais
qu'est ce qu'on veut à la fin je sais
pas vraiment mais sinon si quelque part
je pense qu'on ne veut pas détruire le
système
on veut simplement le coloré on veut y
apporter une touche totalement
différente
on veut faire en sorte que ce système ne
soit pas le seul possible car c'est un
système qui est efficace
il a tenu si longtemps aussi parce qu'il
a des réelle richesse mais il ne peut
pas être le seul possible
un album c'est un format qui est très
intéressant très intéressant de faire
une compilation de douze morceaux de 3 4
minutes mais on ne peut pas se contenter
de cela aujourd'hui alors qu'il ya tout
un tas de possibilités annexes donc avec
ce collectif on essaye réellement de
colorer le système actuel de l'industrie
de la musique
il faut dire que c'est un collectif qui
est très jeune on est né l'année passée
en 2015 et cette conférence n'est pas
une
un catalogue je dirais de nos
accomplissements parce qu'on n'est
vraiment pas du tout un stade
d'aboutissement rooney au tout début au
tout début la réflexion les objets que
je vous ai montré comme le téléphone et
les biscuits c'est une simple ébauche
c'est simplement un début de réflexion
une réflexion qui n'est pas terminée et
on sera probablement pas tout seul à
faire grandir ses idées d'ailleurs si
vous avez une idée contactez nous par
mail ou autrement
et voilà je suis pas venu tout seul
aujourd'hui il ya quelques autres
membres du collectif qui sort du lot
avec moi et voilà on va vous chantez en
bourse
un son
en cuisson
toujours
à son nom
au
jd
et
un indien
après jc
main dans la main
ça y est vous
oh
je suis
c'est ainsi
nous les cours
sans sursis
partageons
ses fruits
merci